oublie la fashion week si je te parle de
la famille royale d'aldo vie qu'est-ce
que ça t'évoque et bien je sais que le
roi est mort l'an dernier et que le
principe osé reprendre ses fonctions et
instable et un mondain à la vie
sulfureuse pourquoi moi tu as du talent
de l'ambition du intelligente et tout le
monde est booké la semaine prochaine
malheureusement
si tu réussis ce reportage ça va
propulser ta carrière
ah oui je suis à l'intérieur du palais
c'est mieux qu'une interview exclusive
fait un maximum de vidéos de photos
réuni un maximum
[Musique]
bonsoir on y va tu vas voir
vous avez l'air totalement fasciné par
mon frère
la rumeur prétend aussi que vous ne
voulez pas renoncer à votre mode de vie
c'est quoi mon mode de vie sipa les
femmes du bape et la musique
alors c'est comme ça que vous imaginez
et je ne connais pas grand chose de vous
en tout cas j'espère que vous serez là
demain soir demain soir oui au bal du
réveillon
qu'est ce que c'est leur mission faire
de toi ils vont
[Musique]
on peut savoir ce que tu attends
regarde parce que vous êtes magnifique
roy peut se sentir très seul vous savez
qui n'a pas sa reine
[Musique]